my sister margaret rose and i
feel so much for you
as we know from experience what it means
to be away from those we love most of
all
i declare before you all
that my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
happy christmas
it's inevitable that i should seem a
rather remote figure to many of you
a successor to the kings and queens of
history
someone whose face may be familiar in
newspapers and films
but who never rarely touches your
personal lives
but now at least for a few minutes
i welcome you the peace of my own home
1992 is not a year
on which i shall look back with
undiluted pleasure
in the words of one of my more
sympathetic correspondence
it has turned out to be an anus or
rebellious
i suspect that i am not alone
in thinking it's so
indeed i suspect that there are very few
people or institutions
unaffected by these last months
of worldwide turmoil
and uncertainty
since last sunday's dreadful news
we have seen throughout britain and
around the world
an overwhelming expression of sadness at
diana's death
we have all been trying in our different
ways to cope
it is not easy to express the sense of
loss
since the initial shock is often
succeeded by a mixture of other feelings
disbelief
incomprehension anger
and concern for those who remain
we have all felt those emotions in these
last few days
so what i say to you now as your queen
and as a grandmother
i say from my heart
first i want to pay tribute to diana
myself
she was an exceptional and gifted human
being
in good times and bad
she never lost her capacity to smile and
laugh
nor to inspire others with her warmth
and kindness
[Music]
i admired and respected her for her
energy and commitment to others
and especially for her devotion to her
two boys
i for one believe there are lessons to
be drawn from her life
and from the extraordinary and moving
reaction to her death
all too often i fear prince philip has
had to listen to me speaking
[Music]
frequently we have discussed my intended
speech beforehand
and as you will imagine his views have
been expressed in a forthright manner
he is someone who doesn't take easily to
compliments
but he has quite simply been my strength
and stay all these years
and i and his whole family
and this and many other countries owe
him a debt
greater than he would ever claim or we
shall ever know
i believe i was last here in 1957.
2 500 delegates and their wives rose to
greet the queen and they represented 82
member nations
since then i have traveled widely
and met many leaders ambassadors and
statesmen from around the world
i address you today
as queen of 16 united nations member
states
and as head of the commonwealth
of 54 countries
in tomorrow's world we must all work
together as hard as ever
if we are truly to be
united nations
i'm speaking to you at what i know is an
increasingly challenging time
a time of disruption in the life of our
country
a disruption that has brought grief to
some
financial difficulties to many
and enormous changes to the daily lives
of us all
i want to thank everyone on the nhs
front line as well as care workers and
those carrying out essential roles
who selflessly continue their day-to-day
duties
outside the home
in support of us all
i'm sure the nation will join me in
assuring you that what you do is
appreciated
and every hour of your hard work
brings us closer to a return to more
normal times
i also want to thank those of you who
are staying at home
thereby helping to protect the
vulnerable
and sparing many families the pain
already felt by those who have lost
loved ones
we should take comfort that while we may
have more still to endure
better days will return
we will be with our friends again
we will be with our families again
we will meet again
but for now i send my thanks and warmest
good wishes to you all
remarkably a year that has necessarily
kept people apart
has in many ways brought us closer
across the commonwealth my family and i
have been inspired by stories of people
volunteering in their communities
helping those in need
in the united kingdom
and around the world
people have risen magnificently to the
challenges of the year
and i'm so proud and moved by this quiet
indomitable spirit
we continue to be inspired by the
kindness of strangers
and draw comfort that even on the
darkest nights there is hope in the new
dawn
i have spoken before
of my deep and abiding affection for
this wonderful country
and of the many happy memories prince
philip and i always held of our time
here
it is often said that it is the people
that make a place
and there are few places where this is
truer than in scotland
as we have seen in recent times
we all know of the difficult
circumstances that many people have
encountered during the last 18
months however alongside this they've
been countless examples of resilience
and goodwill
it is a source of great pride to me
that the leading role my husband played
in encouraging people to protect our
fragile planet
lives on through the work of our eldest
son charles and his eldest son william
i could not be more proud of them
indeed i have drawn great comfort and
inspiration
from the relentless enthusiasm of people
of all ages especially the young
in calling for everyone to play their
part of course the benefits of such
actions will not be there to enjoy for
all of us here today
we none of us will live forever
but we are doing this not for ourselves
but for our children and our children's
children
and those who will follow in their
footsteps